hello the episode y'all have been
waiting for since i started this podcast
is finally here uh i finally
found my straightener and was able to
make my hair look cute enough to have dr
gwan stewart
on the show the most i think requested
uh guests that we get are like wouldn't
even have a veterinarian on what do you
have a veterinarian my thing with
veterinarians is either i don't trust
them or i'm dating them so uh it's
sometimes hard to find the perfect
person but um
i will let you explain how we met um i
got
wildly lucky and as someone that
is
known by most vets in the southern
california area uh
i got to meet you and
it was kind of a magical
thing i got very lucky and got to meet
you uh but i'm going to let you speak
and say i always ask people when they
first come on are we friends and how did
we meet
to clear something up where you don't
you what you don't trust me or are we
dating which family
well i
only date people i don't trust and i
trust you so but i met your boyfriend
yes yes so yeah i'm in the
i don't trust me i hope you we've earned
some trust they're right over the years
i
want to argue hard for reverse mormon
religion why can't one woman have three
husbands if men can have three wives
is he listening right now
he'd be this is gonna
when he saw you talking about watched
him walk up and just go like i'm gonna
let him take this one
he would love to pawn me off on someone
maybe not sexually but just to listen to
me uh ramble no but um uh we met in a in
a
i i honestly don't even remember through
a giraffe it was georgia
right do you remember this now i
remember all of it i cannot remember who
put me in touch with brandon mcmillan
that's right
yeah so brandon mcmillan um who helped
me when my dog uh when my dog was bitten
off when my ear was bitten off by a dog
the other thing happened a couple times
too but um my ears bitten off by a dog
that i had rescued and it was not
aggressive it was trying to play with me
it was a very you know traumatized dog
that i had just gotten from a shelter i
made the mistake of allowing it to be
dominant with me and sleep with me
because i felt sorry for it i was
letting it lick my face and and then i
got up and he just grabbed my ear and my
ear just came off my head
and once the ear was sewn back on my
head i really wanted to find out what do
i the if i need to put this dog down i'm
the first to do it if this is if it's
going to do it to a child or another the
worst thing for pit bulls is that
there's more stories about people
getting injured by pit bulls if this is
a lost cause and i go to brandon
macmillan who does an aggression test
with the dog it's really intense to
watch but he puts two leashes on it and
basically puts in a situation where it's
cornered where it would have to defend
itself and it just like cowered and was
terrified and he's like the star's not
aggressive
so we were able to re-home it and so i
love him
yeah if you survive that yeah
credit to you because
most people one
would have never wanted to go around a
dog again
and probably would have wanted to put
the dog down and had everyone around
them you need to put the dog down but
you obviously are more educated than
that there were fires in
california woolsey fires a couple years
ago and my kink
uh my little secret hobby is uh whenever
i'm not doing this or working or doing
stand-up i am just trying to dismantle
exotic animal abusers and businesses and
if i haven't come for you yet i will
uh it is a mental illness i'm very
committed to and proud of
and
for me the exotic animal stuff and you
saw me like you know try to get a
giraffe they didn't because if you have
exotic animals
you shouldn't by the way there should be
no private ownership of exotic animals
it's always abuse any apex predators if
you're touching any apex predators it's
abuse lions tigers are bears because
they had to be taken from their mom too
young and it's amazing to me that people
can't go oh my god i'm holding a baby
tiger
and then what's the number one scariest
animal
when they're a mother of their cubs
like do you think that the tiger was
just like yeah take my cubs
please take selfies with my cubs in
thailand for these stupid influencers
i'm getting over so overwhelmed because
i have so much to say about this but i
need to stop talking
yeah about it you're you know so you
know i was in the movie industry yes and
i have some thoughts so we we can touch
on this because it is a big subject and
you're very passionate i know i'm like
i'm like
i start shaking when i talk about it and
you're going to ask me to leave them
because our time is going to be up yeah
no no no no we haven't even got through
how we met because it's also just the
last thing i just feel the need to like
explain myself only to you because i'm
like i'm like i feel like he thinks i'm
so crazy because i was running around
trying to save a giraffe like that was a
very intense like you saw me i mean that
was like a six seven month thing and it
did it is gone now you know what i mean
and
because
any time there is exotic animal
trafficking or animal abuse there's
always some kind of other abuse or crime
going on whether it's drug trafficking
human trafficking or arms dealing so for
me part of the reason i say if there's a
lion in that guy's backyard
there's definitely some thai girls in
the basement yeah like you're going to
be connected to some kind of crime
exactly like nobody is like abusing
animals and then they're like cool to
women and children you know what i'm
saying so it's like i'm always like this
is a symptom of a bigger thing and so
that's why i just i get when people just
want to go like why is she so obsessed
with zebras it's like it's not about
there's more going on there so so now
that you're sweating uh
ah because i was like keep it short in
my brain when i when i
talk about that i just i know i get very
overwhelmed and i was like keep it short
but let me uh ask you okay so that's how
we met you were so kind to me and
patient with me even though you're like
this
well i didn't even i mean i had heard of
you and so brandon gets me on the phone
and says i have a friend who's sort of
in crisis mode about this giraffe
dealing with fire can you talk to her
and you just come on and start talking i
didn't i didn't you know he said it's a
friend of mine whitney
and i was like i got all the documents i
got the
you just went with it and
and no and
i you know one i was just here to listen
to i think hopefully i gave you some
advice and we got through it you're
right you stayed on it for six months
until that thing was fixed and
i was like this she is on another level
you are when it comes to this stuff and
it's impressive it's impressive the cool
thing about when we met is we'd never
actually obviously met in person we were
talking on the phone three-way with
brandon
and i was in san diego
and you were on tour and that very night
you just happened to be in san diego and
i don't know how i found that out la
jolla in latoya and
i think i texted you and said
hey we were talking earlier you're here
do you mind if i come to your show and
you put me right up at the front we met
she you know give me a big hug and we've
been fast friends ever since that is so
true and also i think that you know for
everyone tuning in that is like oh i get
to hear a vet talk for the next couple
hours um hopefully i'm able to get to
everybody's questions um
there was a there's a calmness to you
and there's a um
there's just there's is this something
you've always had because sometimes you
go to a vet
and the energy of the you're like iron
this is already i'm already so stressed
out that this person is now this woman's
coming in in high-heeled clogs and she's
got a bedazzled laminate which in her
you know and you're just like why is
your hair down you're
are you getting hair in my dog's spleen
when you're you're doing surgery with
your hair down like there's just some
you know things will happen like you
have this such a calm and did you always
have this
um or is it a result of being a vet or
is that why they're sitting there
looking at me funny i don't i mean i
no i think um when i was young i had
i was a little bit
of the class clown i wanted to stand out
and and part of the reason that and and
this is this is touching on some
personal history is
i'm i'm biracial my dad's black my mom's
white and i grew up in the 70s at a time
when
i just looked weird to everybody else
right it was me who had the funky hair
that didn't lay down right didn't it was
always in the middle stage of growth
and had braces i was really really thin
and i just got teased a lot that you
know back in the 70s like bullying was
an art form right do you remember
like
kids could just beat you up with words
as soon as you said you were skinny i
was like he was in a couple lockers
i mean we used to people would put me in
lockers
i was in a locker for like four hours
like the kids i feel like
are it's not the same level of bullying
it used to be
yeah you're gonna bring back traumatic
memories but it was it was through high
school i had this
i didn't kiss my first girl until my
senior year and it was it was rough and
then i finally came into my own
um so i think the only way when i was at
age was to get any attention from girls
was it's like costanza said like you
know like you had to develop a
personality
i got to become a vet yeah i gotta i
gotta do something because this isn't
working man i gotta get a date
eventually um but you know it's funny
when i entered college and started to
come into my own i yeah i have a much
more sort of level
balanced demeanor and then i've been
i've been in this field whitney for 25
years and i've done emergency work and
i've seen i have seen it all i was a
shelter vet i've seen puppies come in
in barrels that were dropped in the
local river with the top hammered shut
so they could suffocate as they floated
down i mean i've seen some horrific
things
and when you're in these moments
you have to manage your team
and if you're falling apart then then
your team picks up on your energy and
they they go haywire so
it's just you know it's it's time and
seeing a lot of things good things but
really bad things because
you do start to lose a little bit of
your faith in people and humanity when
you see some of the things they're
capable of especially
to little
innocent kittens and puppies it's not
like the number one way you're able to
tell like a kid is a sociopath or a
psychopath because when they mistreat
her put the battery acid on a dog and
set it on fire or whatever did you see
making of a murderer
uh i did remember that documentary that
went on and on that was yeah and then
they came out with a part two i did yeah
they spend ten hours trying to figure
out this guy's guilty
six hours in
we read from his uh his girlfriend's
journal or someone was like oh yeah one
time he was a kid he threw a cat into a
fi a lit fireplace and it ran out and he
threw it again i'm like that's done it's
a wrap the show's over yeah we know
there's four more episodes after this
like we're like we're done here why
don't you lead with that like why you
guys you just wasted six hours i could
have told you this guy was fucking
guilty if you just like
let me talk to his childhood vet i could
have told you you know so it's uh that's
something that that you know i went into
um the uh access woodland hills
uh but it was before the pandemic and
there was a sign that said
you know to people in the lobby
basically saying like hey we love being
your family vet and just fyi one out of
six veterinarians contemplate suicide
it was like a be gentle like because
i'm always the bitch that's in the lobby
like telling people like do not talk to
her like that you cannot they're very
stressed out like because it's like
you know the way it's also the way that
you see people at their worst even when
they're not bad people and then you see
bad people
do horrible things yeah so i'm glad you
brought this up because i get this a lot
right our our suicide rate
um it's funny i was at a bar one time
with a friend and
her friend comes up to meet me
and she said i heard you were a vet i
said yeah she's
the first thing she said i've never met
this woman in my life and she says
you guys have like a really crazy high
suicide rate
that's how she opened the conversation
and
i said yes in vet offices now it's all
over the lobbies what's that in vet
offices now
oh
emergency rooms and stuff it's all over
the lobbies
and it's a
i've given this thought and i'll tell
you when i was doing the shelter work um
this was about 10 years ago i was a
shelter vet for five years i hit a low
too and i was euthanizing
30 to 40
up to 50 during cat season
dogs and cats before 10 a.m a lot of
them healthy
and
you know it it killed my soul i there
was a moment where i thought about
getting out of the profession i felt the
low but again i would go into work
because i'm leading this team
i felt like i had to put on this good
face but there were many moments i had
to go out and take a walk and like i
would tear up i can and all right let's
go girls we got the afternoon let's do
this
but it it started destroying me and you
know here's the thing about
veterinarians we
you talk about if you ask most animal
people veterinarians why did you go in
the profession what drove you one of the
first things a lot of them will tell you
is
it's
because i i hate dealing with people
like it was either medical school or
veterinary school but i don't want to
deal with people so i'm going to go
treat animals the sad thing is or funny
thing is we end up dealing with people
and sometimes very
erratic people just as much or more
in the veterinary field
but
you know going back to why why
why is our rate so high and i my theory
is this
you get
people that
since they were kids have loved animals
right and we're just animal lovers too
at our core
um we're very emotional
um compassionate people then you put us
in a profession
where we are required unlike any other
profession
to euthanize and destroy our patients
on a regular basis and then take that
home
like of course over five 10 15 20 years
you're gonna feel the burnout and then
how many people do you have to give bad
news to during yeah so i'm yeah i'm
sitting in front of in front of you know
the pet parents and
you know they've lost
a family member they've had for 15 years
i'm trying to counsel them meanwhile i'm
going through my own thing if i you know
if this is a patient of mine
that has now become like my own pet for
15 years i've seen it through many
things and then i'm having to put the
needle in it i have never thought about
that before
i've literally never thought about that
which part that well just the fact that
oh my gosh just the fact that like
the vet that treats my dogs has an
attachment to my animals like it didn't
even occur like it didn't even occur to
me that a lot of the
the in my brain it's just like a dog
just got hit by a car and you have to
put it down it's like it's also the ones
that you've been seeing its whole life
yeah i'm not a cold robot i have never
thought about that before and i am
gonna hold it together when you grow up
living animals and i have to see the
light go out of the eyes of this
dog this dog that's meant everything to
you wow and then i have to go back and
have my moment yeah and go back to work
and then do the puppy exam right after
like it is this rise and fall of
emotions and it's tough man and then
you know on top of it i've had many
years where i've dealt with insomnia and
of course that that mix doesn't help so
you know we we go through it and
um
and let me ask you really quick because
right that made me think of just one
thing and i'm gonna try to um distract
myself from the sadness that will never
stop if i think about that more
especially since since you're my friend
and i love you so much thinking about
you having to do that now is making me
like very sad um but uh
but um in addition to all that the
uncomfortable thing to talk about is
that a lot of times
there's a way to fix a dog or save a dog
or something and and a lot of people
can't afford it which just brings me to
pet insurance guys get your pet
insurance so i didn't so you're a big
advocate for that i mean i
don't have it it's too i'm too far gone
i can't get it now but i could for a new
pet but from what i understand it's
really helpful for people i don't think
it's help it works for dental at all but
and there there are some packages that
are more comprehensive than others and
i'm yeah i'm surprised you brought it up
because i think that is the solution so
going back to the other you touched on
it the other major thing i have to deal
with
is
telling someone i can't treat your pet
because you don't have money so the the
devastation on their eyes when they've
come in and it's just it's just an
accident when you get a dog or cat it's
not about if it's about when so you
paying that 30 40 a month for your pet
insurance you know there will be a two
four thousand dollar bill whether it's
next week because there were a car came
by and you left the gate open or if
there's cancer in the future there's
just no some sort of cardiac disease
something is going to happen
you're going to need a prescription
you're going to need a whatever it is
and a lot of them include vaccine stuff
which i want to talk to you about in a
second um and uh there's no reason to
not get it just if you if you cannot
afford the 30 a month for the pensions
just don't get a dog wait till you can
because that will change your life and
and
more times than i can count i've had to
tell somebody in that moment because i'm
not the practice owner maybe i'm an
associate and i have to tell that person
it comes out in a business decision i
more than i want to
this is what i can do i can alleviate
the suffering
and i can triage your pet
but
this broken femur that's going to cost 2
500
i just that i can't do and then what
happens is they blame me of course
you're you're gonna you're gonna let my
dog die of course you're gonna kill my
dog and that's and then i carry that
home well see that that is totally
unfair and i understand being in grief
and needing someone to blame to feel
better but the the the vet is not the
person to do that too it drives me nuts
and it's like yelling at the flight
attendant because the plane's sitting on
the tarmac for 40 minutes like she has
no like this isn't her fault you know
you're just yelling at an innocent
person
who's already in pain about this you
know what i'm saying i'm already in a
situation where i have to deliver you
bad news and cannot save this patient
because as much as i want to but here's
the other thing i'm the bitch who will
go oh you have a 2500 breeder dog but no
health insurance for this dog and then
you're going to say you can't afford it
stop buying dogs yeah how about that how
about rescue a dog
use some money to train it do whatever
you need to do and then get pet
insurance so when something bad happens
you actually can
pay for it yeah i just jumped on board
with the big pet insurance
company here called fetch and i i am a
huge advocate of retaining pet insurance
and the other thing is
um not optional yeah right it is a
trickle-down effect then we spread it
out of course some people can use it
more than others but everybody gets the
care and i don't have to be the bad guy
yeah
yeah i mean there's a couple things also
it's like i i just think it's important
like and this is part of the reason
we're doing this podcast and i think we
should do it kind of regularly because i
guess for someone that spends so much
time in vet offices with veterinarians
like in the animal world like i'm like
oh i thought this was like common
knowledge i guess there's a lot of stuff
that people don't have time to know you
know or don't have time to learn and if
they don't they're just gonna go on the
internet and get some answer that's not
true or some silly shit so that's why i
want to go through a couple things that
i think are like commonly misunderstood
uh things and also um a couple like life
vet hack sort of thing so let me ask you
what do you feel like are the most
preventable things that you see
well i can start by telling you
that are the owners fault what are the
most common things we see in the er and
we could
we could probably reverse engineer that
yes so
um dog fights we see a lot on emergency
so
during the summer dog parks
dogs not trained no need i'm not a big
dog park person there's just no need
this guy is not neutered this one's not
neutered they're not really trained
dogfight i see him people are flirting
talking they're on their phones filming
i've seen it all i've the number of
buttholes uh i've had to put my finger
in in dog parks to try to get dogs to
stop fighting that's what that's your
method okay
[Laughter]
you can grab them from that behind the
hind legs that's what you're supposed to
do but if you're
oh no i do it after just later just for
fun oh okay all right
just show him his box just to relax all
right but you do you start by grabbing
them
but you have to have someone else
grabbing likes of the other one do you
know what i'm saying right so i'm glad
you know that so in the shelter and not
a lot of people do they want to go up
and try and kick them or put their hands
in the middle and they get tore up you
are supposed to and i had to do this
two dozen times plus in the shelter and
there's pit bulls going at it in these
small cages i have to send one person in
with me and at the same time each for
anyone who's wondering how you really
break up a dogfight you each grab the
hind legs at the same time and you just
sort of jerk them or drag them yes pull
them away so that they're basically off
the ground entirely yeah you know
essentially and then sometimes i'll grab
two and just because usually then you'll
put the finger finger in the butt
because then they'll whip around they
really want you know what i mean yeah
dog fights for venable yes use a leash
train your dog
get them neutered
take precautions and if your dog does
not stop what it's doing as soon as it
hears its name it's not a dog park dog
so i i had to send my dogs to uh 28 days
of impulse control training so that it
was whatever they're doing whether
they're chasing a squirrel and i say
their name they stop like if they're
that distracted and have that much
dopamine and like ancestral drive they
still stop and if they don't they don't
get to go to the dog park yeah no dog
park so that's preventable so i see that
a lot number two common thing number two
toxicities food we can talk about you
know food toxicity and you can look all
that up there's chocolate and
onions chocolate is it just because of
the is it it's not because of the dairy
and chocolate it's because of the the
caffeine no there's a toxic element
called uh theobromine
it's an ingredient a name you don't have
to remember but there's something in
chocolate okay and it's in higher
quantities in dark chocolate interesting
lower quantities and milk chocolate and
almost zero in white chocolate
so it is this element interesting okay
yeah so chocolate also don't feed your
dog white chocolate yeah they don't do
it for fun
it shouldn't have a toxic event but uh
yeah so onions garlic
mushrooms there's a list of stuff you
can and there's an acronym sometimes i
use somewhat easy to remember is mom
gang x that contains a lot of the toxic
foods in this acronym mom
gang
s yeah what's wait let me start with x
x is xylitol
so whoa
yeah you'll see that in gum macadamia
nuts oh macadamia nuts never would have
gotten that okay gang g
think of can you think about ganja
i didn't put that in there but yes
green peppers
um it's uh it's
it's not a spice but it's it it it's
gonna make your breath smell bad you
don't want to eat it before you're gonna
go make out with your guy
garlic yes all right i got you there
well i only date vampires okay
garlic a a a avocado we don't see that
as much and it's usually the pit so
that's not a big one oh like they choke
on it or something chew and choke and
there's yeah i know what n is
nutmeg good all right g the last g in
game another g yeah
pat
grapes hey
ding ding ding
grapes and raisins yes because of the
seeds huh excuse me no there no no
there's an element in grapes and raisins
that um
[Music]
oh like resveratrol i mean i like the
skin
of the skin of it or something no i
think it's in the flesh um
see this is where i'll have to like dip
back into it so no wine got it
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter why
like it doesn't my thing is it also
doesn't matter what i can go into what
each one causes but it doesn't no one's
gonna remember it just remember yes and
i think the thing that people do is
around something like thanksgiving a lot
of these these are in
mom's stuffing right yeah and so let's
give the dog some stuffing
raisins nutmeg
onions and all kinds of things
you know yeah all of this oh my god moms
have been trying to kill the family pet
for years stuffing is literally
everything you just said it has just
except maybe i don't know maybe they're
probably wild
yeah but so so that's people get
thanksgiving christmas these big events
that's why we see a lot of toxicities
all right
um and then what about like bones
from giving dogs scraps from the table
like that is the most common sense
thing i can think of and yet people do
it let's give my dog this chicken bone
and see what happens
and
like the smell like a marrow bone like i
often will do like a big marrow bone if
my dog's gonna be in the crate for a
while or something or i'm trying to like
lose some weight i'm trying to whatever
but um or like have a puppy that's
teething but a skinny like wishbone tiny
bones splinters is and it's going to cut
the intestine or pierce it and perforate
it and then you're you're coming in and
clogging up that's a big one
that's a big one yeah uh
some things that maybe aren't
necessarily preventable but we see quite
a bit things like seizures um sometimes
it happens as a result of toxicities
heart disease don't blow weed smoke into
your dog or cat's face
i shouldn't have to say this
well maybe you should maybe we have to i
think i'm saying more for myself than
anyone else but why are you reminding me
i know the temptation i know what that
temptation is when you're high
you're like
wouldn't we call my dog was i too do you
want some of this yeah just like
just don't don't do it i don't know how
else to say it the dog is not looking at
you saying don't bogart the joint
in your mind you're like oh he wants to
be high too whatever your brain is
telling you it's just put your dog in
the crate why do you smoke weed how
about that dude do you wake up in the
morning with like a checklist of stuff
you shouldn't do like that just to
remind yourself in the morning don't
blow
until i go
daily reminders
love yourself
life is good do not blow weed smoke into
your dog's face um but no i mean there
for me i do wake up i mean i have you
know a a
i i'm not gonna say how many dogs i have
because animal control might be
listening but i do wake up every morning
i have my coffee and i look around on
the floor or is there a candle on the
floor is there something like i have to
look at the floor to see what detritus
could be around you know lipstick makeup
something fell on my purse or there's
like bully sticks one bully stuck is on
the floor and if there's one bully stick
and you have three dogs that could be a
dog fight and a heartbeat you know it's
like if you have
animals in your home you do have to
spend a little bit of time
doing uh like
dog proofing cat proofing like hygiene
you know don't be mad that your dog you
know choked on you know the wishbone
that you left on the floor why did you
allow that to be on the floor it's a dog
it's a dog
dogs are gonna eat what's on the floor
it's your job to set the animal up to
win
common sense common sense
clean your home you hoarders put it all
on shelves the way i do
i don't have so many dogs
how dare you rude
they're not dogs they're my children all
right sorry sorry vaccines i know this
is the like most politicized thing in
our country right now we're talking
about animal vaccines
i know and look if you don't want to
talk about it
fine because i know that this is a
tricky one what i would say
is we don't
i am i'm gonna ask i live in california
southern california
uh arizona albuquerque with your brother
san francisco
texas
do i need a lime disease vaccine
maybe maybe so it's case by case so
here's the advice i would give and does
someone in the hamptons need a
rattlesnake
one
you know what i mean right right that's
a good point and
so one the rattlesnake vaccine is sort
of hard to get yeah anyways um and
getting anti-venom is really right so if
you live in california and you have a
lot of land and you have a dog that's
running around sniffing stuff uh all
dogs uh make sure you know where the
closest vet you is that has anti-venom
yeah yeah cause you might take it to a
vet and they're like oh we have to send
you that other vet yeah
you're right so
um and then if a dog does get bit by
rattlesnake you
pee on the wound
i mean
and put your finger in the ring
and sit and you pee on the wound and put
a finger in your own butt yeah well
is that what you did
okay luck
don't check the ring camera is all i'm
saying
this is a time sensitive issue so if
you're doing that then
i have to make a phone call
i'm going to be right back
um lime all right ticks so again if
you're in a tick endemic area
you're going for the mountains we see
more lime in northern california um
look you're right the vaccine issue it's
sensitive i i'll get in the room
and
i just feel like how am i going to avoid
talking about this without touching on
covid right because yeah right it's it's
so red and blue and political and and
now they're you know i have people
clients saying well i just don't want to
over vaccinate my dog and that's fair i
mean we've been over vaccinating dogs
and cats for a very long time with good
intentions like obviously good
intentions yeah yeah like it's like
rabies stuff like that like
that was all very important but now i
just feel like there's and this could be
me projecting i mean there just feels
like a little bit of a racket that's
like because with horses you have to be
very careful you can't give a lot of
vaccines at once they can colic so i
always just want to challenge and go
just give in my dog's lifestyle exactly
is this something necessary so if you
have a dog park dog a hunting dog a dog
that's outside on a farm all day by all
means lime but like if you're living in
an apartment in new york city or
albuquerque or apartment living is that
a different situation do you know yeah
and so you really just have to kind of
lean on your vet um i
earlier in my career are you still in
vaccine clinics in southern california
used to run vaccine clinics vaccine
clinics so this is where you sort of you
know cool she sat up like this is what
is this
i know
i just love talking to like really smart
brilliant people that just say something
so casually like i used to run a vaccine
clinic you're like
what like that's just a wild thing to me
well i i work for a company and i was um
you know cmo chief medical officer and
we ran 50 vaccine clinics in like three
different states and
it's it you it's not the craziest
concept you go to petco on a saturday
morning and there's a line of 30 people
with their dogs and they're there to get
inexpensive vaccines
i didn't have time to really educate
these people it was just like you give
them everything give them everything
this little poodle comes up and i don't
have time to get a history and really
you know dig into what your lifestyle is
it should be case by case yeah and
that's where it's gone i'm not saying
vaccine clinics are bad but you need to
be able to have your doctor's ear for
five minutes to explain yeah this is
what they can be exposed to that's what
they're a risk for we're about to get
into the feeding issue which is way more
uh flammable than the vaccine
issue which is
you know i i'm the person that
loves my animals so much
and
i'm one of those people that because i
you know i don't have biological
children yet and when a new food fad
comes out i'm like
i'll do it i'll like absolutely so the
raw food came out and the whole thing
with raw food was like uh it's amazing
how we're just going back to amish like
the new the most modern thing you can do
right now is just be an amish when
everyone's like we're using charcoal
toothpaste now it's like
we have
why are we undoing progress like i do
feel like there's a couple we're like
raw food it's like you know
i think there's something in our brains
that's like oh yeah like there's no
chemicals and it's all natural like you
don't even think about why they stopped
doing raw food back then
we you know what i mean sepsis germs
germs yeah your dog can get bacteria and
sepsis you know it's actually really
dangerous to feed raw food diets like
that i mean i'm sure there is an
iteration that
is uh not black and white where you can
do sometimes under certain conditions
but if you just have a bunch of meat in
the freezer for a year and are like d
thawing and giving there's only a matter
of time yeah so so no raw food diets if
anyone's wondering because inevitably if
you're preparing your own home diet
you're going to screw it up eventually
yeah right and you're also exposing
yourself to a bunch of raw meat and you
know i've heard of people getting
salmonella themselves
you know not
got this stuff you put a black light on
you'd see fingerprints of you know raw
meat all over the counter so yeah you
have to be careful and so no no no raw
diets we've gotten away from that that
was a fad the other one you're about to
mention is the grain free and i didn't
know
that two of your dogs are being treated
for cardiac disease because you bought
in to the whole grain free train yes i
did so
five six years ago the whole great
because i think a big mistake pet owners
make is we go oh this is good for humans
i'm going to treat my dog the way i
would treat myself like when people you
know want to feel like grain free people
humans are starting to go grain free
because
that
evolved for different things completely
different needs like you know and it's
it's almost like just a narcissistic
maybe just like ignorant or wishful
thinking thing like oh yeah grain free
like that's a trend gluten free that's
what we do it's like good for me yeah
not like they evolved right they need
the is it the thianine or the theamine
that's in it well there's a number of
amino acids they need
the problem is the the grain the legumes
that they've replaced it with have some
effect on cardiac function
and you know this now yes so so
uh dr waterman love you uh comes in i
have a dog that is
six and eight and she's like this is it
breaks my heart i've she's she's i see
this all the time people did grain free
diets they started doing it five six
years ago and dogs are coming in uh with
like thinning of the lining of the heart
and i have one on pimobindin and one on
sodalol and they're on them for life uh
because i was feeding
these like
natural diets that were quinoa and and
some chicken but like peas and carrots
which people just throw in to make it
look
appealing or just like look cute you
know what i mean and uh in your brain
you're like oh this must be healthy
beans peas and lentils is the worst
thing for your dog's heart over time
yeah run from those no beans peas or
lentils see those ingredients and then
it's basically stripping other things
that your dog really needs
and to that to your point when a dog
doesn't or cat when you start talking i
need to say dogs and cats um i just
assume cats don't need anything from
anyone at any time
i assume they cook their own meals like
i have no clue
if they
need any help but when an animal uh in
general is lacking in a vitamin a
mineral they'll usually go get it sort
of themselves that's why you see horses
eating poop when uh your a dog is eating
poop or grass isn't assuming it's not a
puppy or just you know an anxiety thing
or like they were homeless and just
learn to do that isn't it normally them
trying to uh get vitamins that they're
not getting out of their diet
or sometimes
minerals nutrients they're not absorbing
in their diet they're trying to trying
to recycle
so yeah it can be for a number of
reasons sometimes grass dogs have this
this bad habit of just eating grass and
it may not actually signal something so
i don't always get excited about dogs
eating grass but sometimes eating their
own poop
then yes it's something some we need to
sit down and talk about diet and what
you're feeding and it's i
you know i go to the pet store and shop
for my own dog i have one dog and got
her from the shelter about a year ago
name
cora beautiful little husky shepherd oh
real quick i spayed her two days ago
so finally got my own dog in opened up
my
clinic in san diego papaya
and training my staff and i said as our
first surgery we're gonna bring in cora
and we're just gonna we're gonna do a
dry run with my own dog but
i
so i was a shelter vet as you know
whitney i've done over 10 000 space and
neuters like that is if i have one
strength i can whip through a spay and
neuter and navigate any number of
emergencies or problems can you tie my
tubes
it'd probably take me three minutes
so cora comes in you'd have to scoop out
all the dead eggs
like a spoon
[Laughter]
oh hey hey hey hey batbap taking a
little break from dr quan stewart do not
use this opportunity to go dm him and
ask him on a date i mean you can if you
want to but i would like you to if
you're gonna if you're gonna do that
consider a pair of rothies for your
first date with dr stewart
every time i've ever gone on a date i
wear the wrong shoes
i wear wedges i'm doing an espadrille
i'm in the heels i'm like bambi on ice
i've got blisters my toes are bleeding
hot take men don't love bloody toes not
even the foot fish guys dry blood looks
like fungi so
rothy's can i tell you something the
fact that these haven't always existed
make me crazy because not only are these
the most these are the most comfortable
flats i've ever worn i don't wear flats
because they rub the my side toe and i
am your side your hammer toes my hammer
okay easy it's uh
i like the medical term is hammer toe
okay i don't want our uh
mc hammer
coming out doing us i mean i got that
liability insurance so you know what yes
i have hammertoe it's hammer time all
the time over here and these shoes i'm
gonna be straight with you they're not
only like cute i think angelina jolie
like wore these to the airport it was
like a whole thing i wore them around
disney world i didn't get one blister by
the way that is honestly a shoe you can
wear to disney world with no socks that
is actually the greatest endorsement i
have never not been bleeding at disney
world yep and that is that's the name of
my next special i'm still bleeding
because i've been out in my period for
six months but i was not bleeding on my
feet you bled your period all over
disney world sure did well at least
and that means we're running out of time
april is earth month
no literally it means you're parachuting
literally i'm perishing april is earth
month i'm about to return to the earth
and that means a lot of us are giving a
little extra thought to how we treat the
planet when you're wearing rothy's your
footprint feels lighter than ever and
it's not made of blood get 20 off your
first purchase today at rothys.com
whitney that's r o t
s dot com slash witch knee and you can
put them in the washing machine and they
bend in your purse what what coco floss
okay so
we need to talk about coco floss because
i had an intervention about
a year ago uh before we were working
before i knew about cocoa floss where
i went to the dentist and
i guess i just feel like i floss
there's a difference between like
thinking you floss right actually you
have to floss with intention if you
floss like once a month you're like yeah
nailed it yeah yeah and i used to be the
person so psychotic i was just not i
didn't develop this as a habit as a kid
for whatever reason i used to instead of
flossing i would just eat an apple
think in my head like you're a horse and
that's what they do for horses to clean
their teeth in my head that like worked
i was like yeah what my teeth are i have
a chew gum an apple a day keeps the
dentist away such a door so i i went to
the in my gums were
hemorrhaging bleeding and i just was
like i don't like any flossers the
plastic ones are terrible for the
environment and there's such a waste the
other ones that cut your finger they
smell disgusting yeah and then enter
coco
coco floss holds strong super cleansing
and breath freshening with fragrances
like vanilla bean dark chocolate and
sweet pineapple pineapple floss people
yes you will it's like a pina colada
avoid mass breath by flossing daily go
to cocoa floss dot me slash whitney to
get 20 off the four spool set and free
shipping and they are
there's one so cute one little package
of floss will ruin your entire bathroom
all of a sudden you're just in an er
it's cute packaging you can put it out
put it in your purse soup's cute that's
cocofloss dot
m e slash whitney and the discount will
automatically apply to check out you can
also use floss to cut cakes but that's a
different situation that's
c-o-c-o-f-l-o-s-com
two s's
could we scroll up a little
we got that part i though well we had to
spell it though we didn't spell it
that's
c-o-c-o-f-l-o-s-s
emily since you thought floss had one s
dot
m-e-whitney and the discount will be
automatically applied at checkout god i
love when you make a mistake i know
because it never happens
it literally never happens all orders
over twenty dollars ship free in the u.s
free
oh we have some shows coming up on may
7th i'm going to be in vancouver british
columbia at the vogue theater
uh special taping i it's not esp it will
be special but it's for my next
basketball may 13th and 14th at newark
new jersey you heard that right victoria
theater at the n j pack i'm not gonna be
one of those those elitist
uh bumble brains that only shoot
specials in new york and la i am going
40 minutes outside of new york
may 20th i'm going to be at tyson's
corner virginia that's the dc area i'll
be the capital one hall may 21st i'll be
in huntington new york doing some laws
laws at the paramount
june 24th i'm in calgary alberta at
prince island's park sounds sketchy i
will come and see what's up with this
island park june 26th toronto ontario
would be the danforth music hall and
then we have some rescheduled shows
because a lot of shit hit the fan this
past year and i'm shooting something uh
tv show so we had to move a couple
things so cincinnati ohio i'll be there
uh september 8th at the taft theater uh
september 9th i'm gonna be in
philadelphia pennsylvania miriam theater
uh september 10th i'll be in richmond
virginia
at the national that's where emily went
to college spiders
their name are the spiders as soon as i
said that i knew i shouldn't have
because you were gonna yeah that's our
mascot spiders
you nerds we're gonna give you
lyme disease imagine being the
cheerleaders like go get in our way go
spider ghost fighters go spiders give
them lyme disease go spiders you're
spooky but some of them are good daddy
long legs are good be a black widow kill
your husband eat your husband what do
spiders do give them bites give them
bites go spiders go shiners build a web
oh goodness
uh nine people just return their tickets
september 24th i'll be in
charlottesville virginia theirs is the
hornets nope share the cavaliers but the
but what's hornets charlotte north
carolina but then charlotte virginia
charlottesville virginia hornets no
charlottesville is the uva is the
cavaliers correct i know i i know dated
a uva guy i do know that
but who are the hornets charlotte
hornets right but that's nba
north carolina
because they're sure ever talk to me
like this
in that tone again
wait what time i'm joking
god i love when you're wrong
i just love the idea of being really
wrong and be like if you ever talk to me
like that
if you ever embarrass me but you ain't
not knowing the difference if you ever
take that over me again
i was like that's right it's so real
i was like this is the line
good lord if you ever disagree with me
again
in front of my face
in front of my fans
back to doctors dude back to someone who
knows what they're talking about at all
times i don't know but really quick uh
as you uh
remember just i love that you named your
dog cora a lot of people don't
understand you cannot name your dog
something that rhymes with a command
so
bo
stupid
i'm sure your dog's lovely
but when you're at a dog park and
someone's like bow bow bow and i'm like
you
named your dog something that rhymes
with no you know how confused your dog
is all the time you know what i mean
like so
that is like a big thing to me is the
way you name your dog is just really
important in terms of like this and your
cat
it's safety in the future you know so
just like be mindful of what you name
your dog because a lot of people
that i see uh with issues with their dog
behavioral issues is that they have
dogs names that rhymes with the commands
simple that's common sense yeah right i
don't know if i i don't know don't name
your dog shit rhymes with sit you bring
up cats a lot i feel like you're down on
cats no i'm not down on cats i'm not
down on cats okay we gotta talk about
cats i know you just got a kitten uh
how's core doing with the kitten
we're getting there okay
so cats i
want to be a cat person i
am va i understand what dogs value and i
understand how to attune to them and i
understand their language of cats and
dogs i'm sorry of horses and dogs cats
i can't everyone is a completely
different cat there's no common
denominator in any of their behavior
they
i just look at cats as like the mean
girl in high school that like wouldn't
let you sit with them it makes me
insecure i know you don't need anything
from me i don't know how to get you to
like me and the harder i try the less
you like me which is like i'm not like i
just
i need to like meet a cat
that that
sometimes i see those hairless cats and
if one of those becomes available for
rescue i'm like that i could do i cause
you just kind of look like a goblin and
and i i want a goblin
i would love to have a goblin but
cats i just i'm not sure okay so i tried
to rescue a cat okay it's happened a
couple times so beth stern is the the
biggest cat rescue person right and i'm
in new york or like outside new york
doing a show and i see
cats in this parking lot
like in like hiding in a thing and i'm
like oh my god there's like five cats in
there
like homeless cats we gotta get them and
i call beth and i'm like sending her a
video and i'm like we gotta get over
i've got five cats i'll put them on
instagram right now we'll get them homes
and she was like they probably just live
there like someone local's feeding them
they're fine i'm like
well then why why don't why do we
bring them inside ever aren't they fine
i'm just confused i don't know when a
cat is needs to be rescued and when it
doesn't
and like what's an outside cat it just
it's too confusing for me there's too
many sets of rules i don't understand
one time i stopped to to rescue a cat on
in the hollywood hills i see it at two
in the morning i'm coming home from a
spot i had just seen three coyotes at
the top of the hill this
older cat that had like long hair is
just like in the middle of the
intersection i jump out of the car i
grab the cat
like take it to the 24-hour vet i go in
and the woman that works there is like
okay we'll look at the chip but i i
think i know what's going on here and
because it calls the woman and the owner
is like
the cat's left every night this week
it's just cats when they're ready to die
they just leave and you never see them
again so
every night someone brings the cat back
to the vet and it's costing me like 300
a day can you just let it go please
[Laughter]
and i was like
i don't get
cats i don't get
then the the the i was in um where i uh
used to live i see a cat on the street
and i'm like trying to get into oh my
gosh there's coyotes everywhere i'm like
getting the cat and i get the cat i
bring it in i like spend a day with it
and i'm like oh my god maybe i should
keep this because somebody i just found
this straight cat
so sweet and then uh the next day i was
like i can't i have dogs whatever i put
it on instagram
to go like found this cat like
like if someone wants it come we'll do
meet and greets 20 minutes later
my neighbor's like did you just put my
cat on instagram
i was like
why is it out
are cats supposed to be out
what are the rules here
do you know what i mean i
what do you want from me i want to know
like because i'm just saying do i i
would not here's the reason i don't
think i'm going to have a cat because i
can't let them out because because it's
too dangerous
but i also can't have them in my house
because they'll ruin my house
this is where i put it
you've i think you just asked every
question that my daughter the same
questions my daughter asked when she got
her kitten no no there's no set of rules
with cats do what i mean they can just
sit anywhere they want
are you do you want me to sell you on
cats but they just sit but have you been
to someone's house with a cat they're
like on
in on bookshelves like they're
above you
i don't want to be in a space
where a cat is like could at any moment
just fly and squirrel like you're just
cool with the five cats up here
as no one is everyone just fine and then
they've got their little cat like um
like like the roller coaster like people
if you're in someone they have
bookshelves that are covered in carpet
that are only for the cats what is that
called like a play land
for the cats like a cat tree or a hat
tree you walk in and they're like you
like you're just chilling with someone
and you're like why can't i stop itching
my eyes and you're looking there's just
nine cats in a tree like this
this is crazy
i got nothing for you here's the other
thing okay i like cats i think i just
need the there's a lot of dog breeds
that i that just aren't for me
you know like i think everyone's got
their thing i don't think it's a dog
thing or a cat thing i think it's like
breeds within
dog or cat so i feel like there is a cat
out there for me
but this is always what happens i can't
believe you haven't said this yet
because you're you're not this person
thank god but everyone says to me about
their cats they'll go like i have a cat
but he's like basically like a dog
[Laughter]
then why didn't you get a dog like no
but first of all no it's not like what
is that logic like you know when you
hear that
i think you've just like alienated 40 of
your audience
i talk about this all the time i talk
about this all the time they still come
back for more huh cat people you guys i
if i need
something done i ask a cat person they
are the most reliable
honest direct
just cool people i know i wish i could
be a cat person i think i'm just too
insecure
because every time it walks away i'm
like are you mad like are you why don't
you like me like they don't they don't
like you that much
i it's not that i don't like cats i just
don't think they like any of us and
i don't want to hold it captive and make
it love me if it doesn't want to
you just threw a lot at me
but do you feel like
you know
cats in general are harder to get love
from
sure
sure
i need unconditional love with cats it
feels conditional
walker do you have some insecurities
[Laughter]
the fact that i could not
enjoy
like the amazing
magical properties of cats because they
hurt my feelings is so pathetic you're
never gonna get over that i just stick
stay in your lane that's my advice i'll
say i can go to anybody's house i can i
can come meet cora within two minutes
cora will be
very into me my best friend and you'll
be like
cats i ca i can't this almost feels like
a project i need to really jump into can
we how do we get whitney
there are more cat owners in this
country than there are more cats yeah
right
so huge population and
i think we need to like give you a
moment so you can see past it you have
to you have to own one or
parent one
to really see
to understand the relationship but are
they going to do witchcraft on me
of course yes because that's the thing
about cats they're so smart and i can
tell i i
i think it's just like i know you're
smarter than me
and i just
have no power over you it's that
it's in you're right you have
insecurities when but it bothers me too
when they look at me i feed them they
look at me they walk off ten feet and
then they lift their leg up in the end
they start licking you know their
privates as if to say you know f you man
is that what that is
see i didn't even know that's what i
like i need to learn cat body language
so i can learn to communicate with them
but just the the way they like come up
to you and will say hi and then just
like i'm good you're like
like it's just it hurts they hurt my
feelings a cat i've never met hurts my
feelings more than someone i'm in a
relationship with well i yeah there's
you know why because if an animal
doesn't like you you suck like animals
know
animals know they're just they're tough
critics yeah i mean you just have to be
on board with that but also is there a
way to get just one cat
yeah you don't need to start with five
really yeah
the
my um
uh one of my colleagues at work she has
12 cats
and she has like a dedicated small
apartment that's what would happen to me
there's no way i could have one i'd have
to get 12. you might love whitney come
on i would love it i'm sure my thing is
like i don't want
one cat i want a
you want a card yeah what is it a murder
of crows what is it of cats yeah uh so
she's got 12 cats um
let's not say her name because that's
illegal
no when can i catch her episode of
hoarders
she has they have their own apartment
which is crazy and she just goes in and
visits them and loves on them that's
what that because to me like cats have
this like magical quality where i feel
like
like yeah i have to get over this
because i'm like well don't you want to
do something else aren't you bored like
they just always seem so bored
that i'm like don't you want a friend
i'll get you a friend oh now you're you
need another like i would just keep you
you would weigh everything i would just
keep trying to make it happy and i i
feel like i would just be in a constant
state of trying to get its approval yeah
anxiety
anxiety
yeah well
never mind i was going to try and get
you a cat cats are next for me i mean i
know that's next because my guy is a
hardcore cat person he loves cats
okay and there's not one in this house
right now
no
you have to think about it
well i was gonna make a pussy joke and i
was like i'm not going to okay
thank you for saving me is there
something for
that that is different between cats and
dogs in terms of what they can and can't
eat
sure and things that that you can go
wrong with cats i mean that's that is a
whole other path but
here here's like a little interest
interesting tip is
cats are true carnivores so we talk
about trying to give like
legumes or a vegan diet they wouldn't
last
long at all they are hugely dependent on
a complete amino acid profile so they
need meat they need meat yeah
dogs not so much they've evolved sort of
along the same lines as us and they can
eat a mix of foods but cats no cats need
meat
and they can survive on pretty much meat
alone because dogs like i mean for the
most part like the survival of the
friendliest like the way that wolves
evolved into dogs the ones that were you
know the most loyal um
the ones that were friendly enough to
come up and get the scraps from humans
were basically evolving to
eat some of the shit we eat but then
cats were like yeah we don't need you
we've got mice we've got squirrels so
they didn't evolve in the survival of
the friendliest the way here's the thing
about cats is they're also
in my mind this is why they're so
fascinating to me they are
the most
intense
predators
and i'm not talking the big apex animals
i'm talking house cats these things are
stone cold ninjas ninjas they're like
these amazing athletes and so going back
here here's just a small stupid tidbit
about history when darwin took him to
the galapagos
they had a couple cats
that dropped off you know came with him
traveled got dropped off the island and
now the turtles are extinct
like more than just a few species are
extinct because these cats ravaged the
island this island that had never seen a
predator a little tiny predator like
this just ran through the island they're
crazy these cats right now i love cats i
want one right yeah right
they are like the coolest animal really
they are do they what what happened with
the the they just a bunch of species
like mice and gophers and shit yeah a
bunch of species just
they endangered and i think a few even
went extinct over time because the cats
started to populate and they breed fast
ah that is so wild anytime i go to a
friend's house who has cats i always
walk and i'm like okay i just wanna i
need to know where they all are i just
don't want them springing out of nowhere
you know i think it's having when you
have i just have so much respect for
cats and apex predators like that like i
do in like now it's respect for cats
i
am not ready for a cat okay and what's
gonna make me ready i just therapy and
not taking their behavior personally
therapy for sure yes i need i need it
just they're so independent and they
have their own lives going on and i want
them to just love it i think people it
would be nice if
some of your followers write in with
why
cats are great yes and i but i know why
no it's more what do i need to do
to be able to
live with an animal
that ignores you half the time yes
yeah yes
because then i'm like where's she okay
is it okay is if you're thinking about
cats they're like always okay right like
you don't have to worry about them the
way you have to worry about dogs and
yeah you know you can leave to work and
know the cat's cool your dog is tearing
up the place it's got separation anxiety
that's a good point it's running around
but yeah cats are they're
self-sufficient that's a really
interesting point you gotta love that
okay so these are a couple questions
that were written in just as i'm still
there's still a couple of a couple more
things um i want to say number number
one as i'm looking for questions like
just
in your
career like
what is like the weirdest
thing or the weird something unexpected
that we wouldn't know as part of your
well i've been doing this a quarter of a
century so i came out of school
in the late 90s
you're probably going to have too many
jokes about this but let me see if i can
get through it
um
the biggest transformation my profession
has gone through is
it is
by far female dominant
like i
i now work with all women and it wasn't
like that in the 90s and it's it's it's
a evolution that's long overdue
because there was a time where women
couldn't even get into vet school right
all vets were men think 20 40 years ago
give or take but now it is completely
flipped in fact my staff now
is 18
ladies and me i work with 18 girls
um it's called a cult leader i have
these moments where i feel like i'm
in homek with
just a class full of girls i don't want
to do sometimes i you know like i'm 10
years old and and you do i you know
sometimes i feel like a big brother or a
father figure but there are times where
i just like want to
like
i don't know like go away and disappear
so my colleague real quick my funny
story my colleague
what do you mean go away and disappear
why why well i'm going to tell you the i
was having just a stand-up conversation
with a colleague of mine a veterinarian
um great doctor
cool gal and
in the middle of having like a
professional conversation she just she
grabs her stomach
and
and starts i'm going to try not to
embellish too much but she grabs her
stomach and this is just like you and i
talking all of a sudden grabs her
stomach
and starts making these sounds and then
starts like tapping her head on the
table and kind of moaning
and i didn't you know
i thought i asked her is it is your
appendix are you okay
and you know she's doing this for about
30 seconds oh and and then she says it's
my menstrual cramps
and
i just i didn't know i wanted to i
thought i was just going to disappear
why is that well i don't know what to do
there's these moments where you as a guy
i think you're paralyzed you have a
heating pad well all right so you know
what you could have done you know the
best thing to do in that situation
tickler
finger in the bottle
well in that moment so it's funny i
tried to act as normal as i could but i
just never in the moment seen a girl
buckle over and say it's my cramps and
so i you know i didn't i was gonna pat
her on the back and i didn't you know
you just want to say and do the right
thing so she walks off give me a minute
and two of my other colleagues were
standing there kind of afar observing
the whole thing and they started
chuckling like laughing a lot of times
cramps are farts too
period farts
i she probably had to fart let me write
that down i didn't know that
and i had the girls laughing we'll talk
about that and i said what what should i
have done and one said well you could
have
just pat her on the back and comfort her
and the other one said
um you could offer ibuprofen or my doll
or something and so i thought okay well
i mean so it what it's a it's a
borderline sexual harassment
what is her what is her what what is her
job she's a veterinarian so yeah so she
can get ibuprofen herself she knows what
to do yeah she's also a doctor yeah no
she was she was great it was just yeah
it was me probably acting awkward at the
moment and and they s the other two
observing just
saw me wanting to like recede into the
night i mean again because you just want
to say the right what if the what if a
guy came in was like i got blue balls
you're not going to jerk them off
if you're working with my i could just
imagine if you're working with 18 dudes
and we're over there that's what that is
what i do i mean that has been my that's
being a comedian it's just me and 18
dudes in the hallway i'm replaying this
event in my head now and i would have
what i wanted to do would just go up and
like pat her on the back and like kind
of you know give her a semi hug are you
okay because she was she was like
leaning over yeah um but yeah i she came
back a few minutes later and she was
fine and they all kind of had a laugh
because still as long as i've been doing
this with yeah as many women around me
as i've done it still you have these
little
awkward moments but anyway it was fine i
will say this can i tell you what i have
to deal with okay why why okay
when all guys sit down
for meetings
they go oh no
guys will stand up from a meeting and go
i just watched you shake your balls did
i i didn't do that when i said when guys
no one you know you sit down guys go
they pull their pants right to make room
for your balls
so i my entire craft had to watch men
just
do what i mean yeah what if what if
you're always in scrubs
in that moment i got i got a bind or
something caught up and i was like oh
hold on would you what would you do
would you do you offer to let me pull
that well there's not enough put that
down for you ignore it i'm just okay
this is not about me okay something that
i do that i do think is
is
helpful for male bosses is in the
woman's bathroom have tampons
not the scented kind
but like there's someone like if you
could just ask somebody that works there
that does the running or whatever like
let's just make sure that we do have
feminine products in our in our bathroom
that's awesome that's awesome yeah so
i've we've thought that so now you don't
need to ask anything because that you've
already solved it it's if there's
already because the only thing a woman
when that point is like do you need a
tampon like that's all of like oh now i
do have to drive and get one or get it
from my purse or whatever so you've
already done i've addressed it you've
already done it that's the coolest thing
you could have done buy tampons and yeah
but you are gonna be fucked when every
woman in there is on the same cycle
you're really you want my one to take
five days off a month and i was talking
i was explaining this to you this is a
real phenomena right correct over time
your cycles we're witches
you didn't know that yeah it's true like
they start working together they start
their cycles align so
if women spend a lot of time together
their menstrual cycles will align like
i went to college and uh uh i went to
college
when i was in college like my first
roommate i remember within like six
months we were just like was like this
is weird like this is weird and then
moving with someone else like four
months in it's like my period completely
changed to her cycle it was wild
do you want me to check in with you in
like six months from now on all 18 of
them yeah i just i'm just yeah let me
know if you need anything because i'm
worried about you
i'm not worried about
i'm not worried about you hurting them
i'm worried about them hurting you
i'm worried about them doing a sacrifice
on you on the o.r table
i'm just worried about them eating you
have you seen yellow jackets
i mean dude
i
[Laughter]
i don't know if we i love french
bulldogs they're very cute i love
bulldogs they're very cute but like
you're signing up to ha you bet if
you're doing that you're signing up for
a lifetime of being at the vet all the
time and possible emergencies all the
time so you don't then get to complain
and be bitchy at the vet if you decide
to buy something
that is so over bred that it can't
breathe
right you are signing up for a medical
nightmare for
15 years which is fine that's totally
fine just know that don't then get
resentful and pissed that you have to
spend twenty thousand dollars giving it
a new nose because they can't breathe
you know so i think that there's like a
couple
animals like over breeding things that
are you know it's a bigger issue but i
think know the kind of dog you have
understand its ancestry under ask other
people what it's like understand what
you're in for you know and also there's
no such thing as hypoallergenic dogs
no there's not so yeah do your homework
but people get they get so stuck on
this in vogue trend they want certain
breeds they want certain dogs and then
every time 101 dalmatians comes out
there's a flood of dolmations being bred
and sold and inbred and it tells me not
to they have you know when they're in
bread they have the worst behavioral
issues and then i see them in my shelter
i i see these purebred
you know sorry to say crazy dalmatians
come in a lot of them don't make it out
they walk in and they never walk out so
you right you see these trends with
certain dogs and right now it's
frenchies and and you can rescue any
kind of dog you might have to wait a
couple days but there is no dog on pet
finder dm me
like i'll take a nyquil and read every
dm you guys send you know me uh uh
there's no like quote unquote purebred
dog you can't find there's great dane
rescues there's dalmatian rescues like
you do not need to buy from a breeder
it's completely unnecessary and you're
just setting yourself up for a life of
heartbreak
in my opinion uh also oh okay so the guy
that invented the hypoallergenic dog
quote unquote uh put out a statement or
he did an interview with the new york
times
saying it was the biggest regret of his
life the uh the labradoodley things
labradoodle creator says the breed is
his life's regret quote i opened a
pandora's box and released a
frankenstein monster said wally conran
who developed the mop-headed dog the
inventor of the labradoodle the
ubiquitous mop had a designer dog said
that creating the mixed breed was one of
his life's regrets i opened a pandora's
box released a frankenstein monster uh i
bred the labradoodle for a blind lady
whose husband was allergic to dog hair
why people are breeding them today i
haven't a clue i found the biggest
majority are either crazy or have a
hereditary problem
labradoodles labradoodles they're
everywhere here because well people
think that they are hypoallergenic and
they don't but it's not from the ferts
from the saliva right a lot of times
yeah sometimes a dander two yeah but
they're to truly find
hypoallergenic no it doesn't exist but
they're you know that's how they're sold
but it is amazing to me though that
someone i know so many people that have
the hypoallergenic fake labradoodles
like that's the first article that comes
up like you didn't even google
labradoodle
before you got you googled labradoodle
breeder like you didn't scroll down to
the new york times article it says like
like isn't that wild
you guys aren't even googling
no because their friends said they're
cool dogs and this this is what this is
this is my challenge whitney and as much
as i love what i do
i'm competing with
you know the neighbor's
influence
and we talked my mom had this or my
sister yeah or dug the pug on instagram
dr pugh i love you but you're you're not
you shouldn't be giving medical advice i
love pugs but their eyes fall out too
easily
that is random yes
their eyeballs will fall out without
without thinking twice about it they
cough in an eyeball
just it's you're just playing
whack-a-mole with their eyeballs the
entire i've seen it happen that's not
true
have you ever seen a pug get shook by a
bigger dog and the eyeball shoots out
have you yeah okay i had to push it back
in
that was it
i put the eyeball just in the butthole
to save it
so that it would stay warm by the time
we got to there's a theme that keeps
coming up and i don't know why you but i
do have a family member that sat on a
shih tzu and the eyeballs came out
of it what is it called shallow ocular
shallow eye things well it's it it's
right and so they have exothalamus they
have like bulging eyes so they
what's what's the term again
what what i say
what's the medical term for their
bulging eyes
exothalamus excellent thalamus x that's
pretty good
eh
because when i had violet the uh uh
really starved sharpay
she had the entropy where it was when
the eyelids entropian entropion right
where they flipped inside and the
eyelashes were scraping her eyeballs it
was like a whole night to like hold her
eyelash like eyelids open for like four
days until we got into the surgery you
could play like a vet on tv almost like
you know what i would be good at it i'd
be very good at that it'd be a quick
study yeah like i mean i'm good at
bullshitting
no
i could definitely come off
as if i knew what i was saying i believe
most of what you tell me
i'm probably going to rethink that
no for all these years away
most of what you've told me there was no
giraffe in malibu
i got it i got it toys r us i knew it
brandon set me up
this is why you're performing in music
no so i don't i i just everyone keeps
requesting that i sing diddies and i
don't know why so i just wanted to throw
that in there everyone keeps requesting
that i diddled them it's the most common
request i get and now we're derailed i
just also want you guys to know that
emily showed up for work today with not
two not three but four
vibrators
monday.com saves us hours of time so we
can focus on creative work like
emily talk bringing in vibrators and we
can laugh about things that are actually
funny like emily's stand up unlike
endless work processes it's a work
oh s it's a work operating system that
teams of any size and any industry why
would they just write operating system
it's a work os that teams of any size in
any industry can use to build right any
industry all either comedians
even us we use it
whoa we use it yeah it is by the way
pretty amazing that comedians can figure
out how to it's not just a bunch of
suicide notes it's lists it's scheduling
it's workflow so it's basically totally
catered to what you guys do so there's
also like a sobriety album
there's a dating app
uh and it works for small teams huge
teams it's amazing it's really keeps us
on track with monday.com work os there's
nothing your team can't do sign up for
your free two-week trial at monday.com
podcast again sign up for your two free
week trial at monday.com
podcast here's my pitch for monday.com
tagline ready yeah let me hear it
stop letting stuff that matters to you
slip through the cracks
how was that
[Laughter]
hey
you guys can use that
i want for every uh every uh brand now
i'm gonna pitch a tagline i think that's
great okay you know what we're doing
we're thriving
for yourself
i was
you know what we're doing marketing
thrive market where were you when i was
a kid inhaling chemicals
while my mom was cleaning my bathtub
with clorox
and not rinsing it talk about a diaper
rash
you want to know why i interrupt so much
i got corks in my butt yeah it's called
having a tick from the amount of well
ticks i had on me as a kid but also the
amount of chemicals i inhaled thrive
market enter thrive you can shop
everything from healthy pantry
essentials and sustainable meat to
seafood and non-toxic cleaning and
beauty products all delivered right to
your door can your grocery store do that
didn't think so punk
join thrive market today and get 40 off
your first order and a free gift for
worth over 50 dollars what
how do you spell thrive m that's t h r i
v e market dot com slash g f y to get
forty percent off your first order and a
free gift worth over fifty dollars
that's thrivemarket.com g f y thrive
market dot com slash g f y and we said
it five times because most of you grew
up not having it and it ruined your
brain cells you had to say three times
we said it five times but we think we
only said it once and i can't add
thanks uh window cleaner from the early
90s thanks electric blue liquid okay so
i'm going to come up with mymarket.com
okay ready go
market.com no thrivemark.com
thrivemarket.com
guys
there's easier ways to get
high that's so good
wait are you coming up with these right
now just on the spot
damn i have a weird skill i have a i
have a tagline skill and a jingle skill
that i feel like i've been sitting on
i mean i feel like that's my main
this is phase two talent in life
back to kwan stuart sorry quan
where are you on uh
ex birds you're uh i saw you on your
instagram you've got some birds which i
would like to talk about real quick the
street vet so this is really
the thing that is um if you guys didn't
think he was an amazing person already
get ready to
fall in love and uh cry do not resist
the urge to send nudes to him in his dms
after i tell you this but um dr stewart
gives free home uh vet care to homeless
uh pets on the weekends on the streets i
do yeah yeah thank you no i
and i'm
probably going to want to ask me what my
like most i don't know heartwarming
moment is since i've been and i didn't
know it's about 12 years but then i'll
have my oprah moment i'm going to tear
up like you did it earlier so i'm not
going to do it don't ask me but i have
been doing this for quite a while and
it just it was a side passion for many
years my own brother didn't even know i
was doing it but i
to be able to give back care to people
that are actually grateful you're right
yeah
well no i mean honestly going back to my
my days of the shelter when i was
euthanizing all those pets i
i
felt like i was
gonna go to hell one day i mean i just
felt like i was doing something wrong
despite everything i trained
to do something right so i
my way of giving back or my way i guess
of redeeming myself was going on the
streets i'd find
people
unhoused people with pets in about 25
years are you not allowed to stay
homeless anymore well
right i guess so there was a time i was
homeless but what we say i guess out of
respect is people experiencing
homelessness or the unhoused got it okay
um so i'd find these folks and about 20
to 25 of them own a pet on the streets
out on the streets
i mean
i mean women uh unhoused temporary on
the house uh
sorry i'm trying to make a joke
i'm like i think i call them future
boyfriends but uh
women especially being homeless having a
dog is like one of the best things you
have for protection protection
but it's it's love it's responsibility
it's purpose
i've heard so many times the people that
own these pets on the streets
it it's it saves them keeps them from
their inner demons like slipping back
into substance abuse or
you know helps with her depression so it
it's
it does a lot for him and and and i'll
be honest with you so i'll shoot you
straight when i started doing this work
i've i had a lot of my own judgments
about
homeless folks i would see a guy an
able-bodied 30-year-old standing on a
corner panhandling and my first thought
was
you can work man go get a job
and it
it kept me from showing in la i was
probably shyla above pretending to be
homeless to research a role the thing
that i took away from it and it took it
was my own journey is
i i would i was judging people i didn't
know and i was writing my own story for
them and i would sort of scan them and
say
no and it would it would hold me back
i've set that aside because i've
realized that these people are on the
streets for all number any manner of
reasons they grew up with no support
they military they met bad decisions bad
luck they just didn't have family to
drag him out or support him a sister a
family member to abuse yeah yeah right
addiction which
people still don't understand as being a
disease and not a choice so i don't i
don't i don't i don't see
that panhandling able-bodied guy anymore
i see someone who's in a moment and just
needs help in fact that's what this
bracelet says it says
no judgment just help and and i sort of
live by that i i see a person with a pet
and my instinct is to kneel down if i
have my supplies and i'll stop my car if
i see somebody if i have the time and
i'll just jump out and and frank's right
there the street corner becomes my
clinic and i'll i'll do an exam and do
what i can and so yeah i that's my side
passion it saved me it kept me in the
profession because as i said i was
probably going to quit about seven eight
eight years ago and going out and living
these stories and meeting these people
and being inspired myself it saved me
and
i
i was about to taste i was about to tell
you the story of like the time that that
got me but i'm not gonna do it i'm not
gonna i don't
you want me to do it i'm just you don't
have to we can cut it out later if you
want all right well
um
there was a gentleman in san diego his
name was mike
and his little companion was a dachshund
named crazy girl
and he called her cray-cray
and and mike was probably a 55-year-old
white gentleman
thin scruffy but like just a nice warm
smile and a very like
nice warm demeter i came across him and
everything he owned was in this push
cart and then he had crazy girl
and
you know she was his life he came from
denver seeking better better medical
care because he had double colon cancer
and been
trying to survive this and he said his
only reason for getting up in the
morning was his little his little dog um
crazy girl and crazy girl
when i happened upon her
had recently gone blind so i looked at
her eyes and they were glazed over and
she could not see
and this had been going on maybe four
weeks and they were so in tune with one
another that he would push the card and
just this the the slightest sound of his
voice she could hear him and just she
would almost walk next to him like she
was on a leash she knew them so well
they knew each other so i've been
together years
and
um
you know he said i don't know how much
longer i have to live and every day i
look at her and it keeps me going
and after i examined her i don't i said
i don't know
if i can restore her vision i need to
get her into the clinic and do a little
more and he said
i would
oh no he said i would um
he said i would gl dr stewart i'll
gladly
keep my
colon cancer if you can restore her
vision
and
and so
and he meant it i mean that's the thing
is he he loved his dog so much he you
know when he said this to me
um he was being sincere he just he
wanted
he wanted everything for her despite him
him being terminal so
i mean these are some of the people i
mean these are these are good people
that just need a lifeline at times and
the part of like
the
medicine that dogs provide is like
she didn't know he didn't have a whole
she that was her you know i mean they
were like
dogs don't judge
cats might a little dogs don't judge us
the way people judge us and dogs i think
for me like they taught me
like unconditional love like i was like
if i could just see myself the way my
dog sees me
i'll figure this out you know i must not
be a total piece of shit if this dog
thinks i'm this awesome you know what i
mean because i respect and love this dog
and i know that they have impeccable
instincts so if this dog likes me like i
must not be that much of a piece of shit
you know and i think that that's you
know the medicine that dogs provide for
people and
you know it the story is i guess like
triply heartbreaking for me because it's
like
it's a man and like
one of the wildest things to me is to
see a guy
you know whether it's someone i've been
in a relationship with or whatever who's
just very like tough and like you know
never cries never shows his feelings
can't say i love you you know dad never
hugged him and then he sees a dog in the
street he's never met and he's like i
love you buddy and you're like oh my god
like
like
so many people are able to have develop
or be let their guard down and not have
to sort of like be tough all the time
because of of having an uh a dog you
know
i don't know how to explain this but and
i'm not a big like toxic masculinity
person but i do think like so many men
have taught you're not allowed to cry
you're not allowed to be vulnerable
you're not about
you know trust no bitch you're not
allowed to like love something or be
weak in any moment and
when i see a man with a dog it's like
their opportunity to just like
it makes me realize i'm like oh my god
there's there's like
we've so acted like men don't have
feelings for so long and then you see
them with a dog and you're like
oh my god that's all in there and you
never get to
society said you're not allowed to have
it yeah you know
yeah yeah i
i i see it play out all the time i saw
it play out with mike and crazy girl and
it's the reason i i love doing this is
when i i see that bond not just in the
streets but in the clinic and
and
it's these relationships that you see
between these people and their animals
and you know here here's something
interesting if you want to know
you know i've i've been asked this a lot
in those those
difficult moments when i have to
euthanize a family pet
and
mom and dad come in
together and it's you know 15 18 years
with this dog or cat
um
and you talk about me this is why i'm
getting into birds birds live 90 years
saying just get a turtle yeah i'm just
saying
and and they
the it's it's at the moment where it's
you know i'm walking them through it and
i take as much time and
uh as i can and answer any questions and
if you want to do it in their lap if
whatever whatever they need in that
moment but but here's the interesting
thing when you talk about men and
emotions
almost invariably
the one who breaks down in that moment
who's acting tough up until the moment
they go down is the guy and he'll he has
arms crossed and not every time the arms
crossed and he's you know looking and
you know and the mom is cradling or
kissing
and then
it's like he he he falls apart like he
just and he you can tell he's been
holding on so long and he's he's loved
this dog so much but
it really is like i mean george carlin
did that um
that bit about like what kind of
monster like how masochistic are we that
you
you get something that you know is gonna
die
like before you die you know what i mean
like dogs like it's this wild like
oh god every time i get a new one i'm
just like why did i do that like in 15
years i'm gonna
like and i planned it all the time i'm
like i talked to my therapist about it i
was like
am i allowed to do heroin for just like
a couple weeks
i'll have doctor i'll be have a doctor
there i've already like talked it
through there i'm like it'll be like two
weeks
i'll just get heroin for like two weeks
and then i'm i'll and then we'll slowly
see if i can not be on heroin after that
there's a ketamine drip you can do where
you go to a doctor's office and they sit
with you and do it so
i i've i've i've got a plan
you've got this through too hard i've
got a plan i'm just gonna try to because
you know why otherwise i'll just get 50
tattoos
and i can't change my hair anymore
colors like the things you do when
you're grieving an animal that you love
so much you start getting tattoos of of
their faces on your body go through a
sudden crisis not in midlife it's just
like we can't get bangs like i'll get
bangs and that's a whole other nightmare
and that'll be a tragedy i'm gonna leave
the euthanasia thing so we can stop
crying but one last thing
euthanasia can be a beautiful thing i
mean to to pull or to alleviate a
terminal
creature suffering
can be
a moment of healing yes and there are a
lot of services now that come to your
home you know right and i i've put down
my own dogs a few times and it was me
and solomon my my favorite doberman of
all time and it was just he and i and i
placed the catherine did it myself and
it was it was healing and i cried i i
melted and fell apart and then is it
safe to say they don't really know
i mean i don't
i don't know i it's hard to say i've
wondered in i've done obviously i've
done this countless times and i go back
and forth i feel like
sometimes they know the end is coming
because things they they sense little
differences obviously right how mom's
acting dad's emotions yes of course and
so yeah probably they know
something know they're so psychic yeah
i've i've already said this uh too many
times and uh i'm gonna have to i know i
have to let you go at some point i'm
just gonna trust that we can do a round
two at some point
really quick yeah i know you had some
questions or probably some probably like
you had a hundred questions i got out
everyone is like about is he single so
i'm trying to get some that are serious
i think we should maybe do this from
time to time where it's just a q a
session ig live and i can hit
i can bang out you know two or three
questions a minute if they're coming at
me and give really succinct answers and
right i don't want everyone to play
google vet you're and you go down this
inevitable rabbit hole when you're doing
this or it seems like everything ends in
cancer or something yeah yeah you're
looking at this list of differentials
and oh my god it has this so yes we can
do that and the other thing is
just go see your vet yeah
you know people seem to avoid like i
don't want to take them in and i've
googled this and you know i've asked my
friend and i went on
dug the pug on instagram no just just
make an appointment and go get a console
from your veterinarian yeah and let the
professionals or become
homeless so you can get it for free well
pretend you're homeless in l.a two legs
maybe that's what the homeless problem
in l.a is a bunch of people found out
they were doing this so they just like
grabbed a tent to pretend
i hope that's not the case
i will say to everybody there's a caveat
to it i can't sometimes i'm restricted
to give direct medical advice to a pet
i've never examined so sometimes the
advice is general but sometimes accurate
general information is better than
50 things you read online so i'm happy
to to field questions and yeah you're
right a lot of times it it want to give
somebody peace of mind i'll tell you
this a lot of times i'm on the streets
examining these unhoused pets
they are remarkably in good health the
animal has a purpose like i'm protecting
like that's what they are bred to do is
just be with their person and just
protect and comfort them
the real problem is that people aren't
spaying and neutering their dogs and all
the animals that you had to euthanize
would have
been eaten by coyotes hit by cars
or
died some other way when you don't spay
and neuter your animals
um
that is what that overloads the shelter
yeah i've come to peace with that i was
at a municipal shelter
that cannot turn animals away that's
like the most humane thing you can do
when you're in that situation it was
tough i mean i can't imagine
yeah that i can't i i can't imagine i
just wanted to say that because i i see
i see like the guilt
on your face like i just see i feel the
you know and it's like i've had to go
like okay we're not talking about just
rescuing animals from shelters because
that's just stopping bleeding that's not
like any real fix so it's like spay and
neuter trucks are like something that
a lot of rescues are working on that
those are the ones that i really work
hard to because i'm like that's actually
preventing the problem and we're not
just gonna run around and be like i'm a
hero i just saved a lab it's like okay
well there's still
four million other dogs sitting in
shelters that are gonna get put down at
some point you know so um what is it 27
million people in america have dogs
is it that it might be more because it's
more than that over the pandemic i think
people got more and it's multiple per
home but there's four million in
shelters so it's like we're really just
asking we just need
20 like 5 million to be from braiders we
just need like 4 million people to
rescue it's not like everyone needs to
do it you know that's just how
we can skew the numbers i look i don't
the whole breeding thing and i don't get
stuck on this
there is a place for responsible
breeding
some people love golden some people love
dobermans
right and you want and you want to honor
these incredible skill sets that these
dogs have i mean a malinois is a
it's a ferrari of a dog i mean it's
capable of i mean these dogs go into
wars and they solve crimes and they find
bombs and we still cannot find a machine
or make a machine that can smell better
than a german shepherd yeah they can
sniff out breast cancer for example wild
it's crazy you know so they're
incredible but if you're if you're you
know the dogs that are just being over
bred to like be cute and it's actually
harming them and their their quality of
life sucks that's when you got to go
like
i don't know about this the english
bulldogs english bulldogs like i mean
yeah my ex had a
it had to get the palette it could first
of all it
they say that they're breathing is like
as if you were to had a like a straw
tiny straw tiny straw and it's
and if it overheats i have a friend who
took her uh her uh english bulldog to
the beach and after seven minutes at
overheating and died
and did you know that most english
bulldogs aren't they're not born
normally they're all cesarean right yeah
that's all c-section that tells you
right there this frankenstein dog is
just
it's just being human manufacturing yeah
exactly so it's like the same thing with
the micro pigs the fake mini pigs
there's no such thing as a mini pig you
know it's like they just starve the pig
so it's like i don't know i'd make sure
that the breed that you are getting no
matter how cute and the blue see
everyone wants the blue eyes on the
aussie shepherds and it's like okay do
you have a farm
then you should not even entertain the
idea of getting this dog
i know people in new york city like i'm
getting this husky
okay do you go on seven mile runs a day
like in what world you know what i mean
um
it drives me nuts i have a request for
you yes and you're crazy busy sometimes
i'll text her she doesn't back you told
me once you had like 100
texts like waiting to be answered on
your phone i'm like how does
yeah hold on i'm just going to answer
two right now how do you wait how do you
go to your
what's like do you want to see how many
texts i have
is that 500 900 get out
where is it
oh top left
941
[Laughter]
yeah when i reached out to like two
months
ago okay
i'm searching
no so
i
i do and i'm serious about this i want
you
and i'm gonna ask all your peeps to jump
on board with this i do i want you to
come with me
and spend some time in the streets i
want you i would love i would feel it
smell it i would love that we were
talking about going on some brief tour
where we kind of bounce around some
places in california well here's the
thing and this is the other bigger
conversation
like
i want this to make this show this is to
me i mean we've talked about it before
the tv business is a nightmare
there's always like false starts and
you're with the wrong team and it's not
working you know the business is
changing so much all the time but i
truly believe that things that are
supposed to be made that are this
magical sometimes it's a little bit of a
you know a laborious thing but you
always want to just do it right the
first time and um forcing something with
the team that's gonna fuck it up forever
is just make something that's gonna be
great a toxic slog you know you're just
in this more ass of like all these
people that you're like having to chase
that's not how it should go and
so to me it was you know
i'm i yes we can do it off camera too um
but also i just like to hear these
stories because you know when you ask
someone about their life that is in a
situation like that you really um
are able to see
like the failures of this country and
like what the results are of it or
you're able to go like
oh this is
this is what
domestic violence this is how it ends or
this is how abusing
uh boyce ends do you know what i'm
saying it's not you know so it's like
just seeing the
or this guy served in vietnam and
there's no place for him to go yeah
this is this is nuts you know so i think
that like being able to put actual human
beings that you get an emotional
connection to on a tv show where you see
that because when you're like going to
vote and it's like the veterans
fund act you're like i don't know the
fuck that is but if you see the
consequence of somebody that went to
serve our country and now is living in a
fucking sewer you know and relying on
someone that's just as kind as you to
come give that like it's just great then
you'll just get fired up in a way
because i think people we've got so
desensitized because it's just there's
too much
pain and there's too much horror and the
news is just like
like violence porn at this point it's
just like like trauma like
that that
things like that we just can't the root
of the problem or just being able to put
a face on the problem it's just it
overwhelms you when you think yeah it's
just like you paralyze like where do we
start what do we do but it it you have
to start somewhere and i mean i tell you
when i walk skid row and i do that often
in fact this afternoon we're gonna go to
skid row
and
the gratitude like the humility and the
gratitude of these people who have
nothing
and would be willing to give me like a
slice of pizza they got for lunch when
they have zero and you come across some
of the wealthiest people you know in la
and they just recoil when you ask for
something or it you know it the greed
that's overtaken this country it
it's really and i think that i think
that you know
when i think that the key to any kind of
change like i'm the person that's like
yeah we need to get rid of zoos because
kids see voiceless things being uh you
know abused and whatever like that and
like like putting a television show in
there that puts faces to these issues
like that to me is gonna someone that is
ken is gonna see that show and go i'm
gonna fix that problem
yeah you know what i mean and so
this like putting thing programming
things that are going to be in you know
homes around the country and world where
p where the next generation of leaders
figures out their cause because
something resonated with them about
you know something that you did and uh
not just the homeless problem uh but
also
all of the things that led to so no one
wants to be homeless
no one might love you no honestly
because you
it's it's not just talk with you
honestly i know
you know
no one paid me to say this
we have connected because you think it
through
um
and you have compassion and you you want
to execute and there's a lot of people
in your position that just wouldn't do
that i worked in la for many years on
film sets i've met many celebrities
and
you you stand out
for for reasons that others don't
thank you and my whole thing is well
it's just kind of like i'm so solution
oriented i do not see any and i think
that when you grow up around a lot of
animals uh and there's a lot of crises
happening so when i lived in virginia
there were 10 horses 15 dogs
endless number of cats and uh people
would just drop my aunt kathy just would
take shit
my aunt would just take uh uh any dog in
you know she was she would go to the
grocery should come back with three dogs
in the back of the truck you know and
people would um take their sick dogs or
dogs that they didn't want anymore just
tie them to the tree in front of our
house so you'd wake up and there'd just
be a new dog you know basted hounds
greyhound i mean there's every dog you
can imagine
and uh
and when there's horses around and that
kind of those kind of dogs and it's like
the fence was you know was an old fence
that broke a lot and horses got out like
you don't have time to talk about the
problem you just have to solve the
problem so for me the idea of talking
about a problem is just
it's so masturbatory i'm like great what
are we gonna do about it you know what i
mean are we gonna make the show we make
the thing like
because so many people just love to talk
about problems like it's their it's i
just i it makes me nuts like i remember
um
i'm not gonna say that because it's
gonna get political but um
so yeah for me i'm like in the amount of
time we've talked about this we could
have just actually done something about
it and it's probably just i'm so
impatient i get bored so easily
but then also to me i have a
i have to finish something like i have
my dad like
instilled in me you never start
something without finishing it like that
is a
that is like the key to integrity is if
you say you're going to do something you
do it and you don't want credit for it
and you do it in silence and it's not
you don't do it so that you get credit
for doing it so the idea is you do it
and you don't tell anybody about it you
know and that was his whole thing and i
see and maybe it's just like
as a comedian i'm like an observational
brain like i always have to look at big
picture stuff and this is something i
have brought up to you
and it might be a next time conversation
because it's a big one of sort of
because of the
embarrassing and gross history of this
country in slavery i see a lot of black
people that are robbed the therapeutic
benefits of dogs because of the
ancestral trauma of dogs hunting them in
the south yeah in the south and then the
unfortunate you know the the you know
stereotype of of uh you know dog
fighting there's you know
i mean miss pat says she's like i grew
up around dog fighting i'm fucking
scared of dogs you know it's like you
saw which is something that you know uh
people that are not able to um
you know get any kind of
leg up in any way have to resort to cock
fighting i mean i'm the first person to
say in africa yeah i hate that they
poach elephants in africa i hate it yeah
the people that are doing it i want to
do it either they're doing it to feed
their kids so it's like it's it's no one
wants to unless you're just like a
psychopath and you're just like jerking
off on a dead elephant that's not the
same thing you know so
i think it's like when you look at the
history of uh
dogs and also i i just don't know enough
about it with with um
uh you know maybe people coming in from
mexico i don't know if they're i just
don't know enough about that but
you know
that is such a
uncomfortable thing to bring up and
we've talked about it before
but it is number one
protection like i think of all these
it drives me nuts when i think about
just like
you know
being black it's dangerous to be black
and just walk around i'm like why
doesn't you need a dog like i i want
every black person that's walking to
their car at night to just like have a
dog you know what i mean like like being
robbed of the protection of a dog and
then the therapeutic benefits you know
from having them like overall
my dad so our dad is multi-generational
south from south louisiana
um we grew up in new mexico he was one
of the first black recruits to the
university of mexico to play football he
went on to play for the pros yeah for
the rams shortly in fact i was born in
new york
when he was i think his mom tells it he
was off playing a game when i was born
he was he's seven years younger than me
so he's like i don't know i wasn't
around but um
yeah so but my dad as much of an animal
lover as i am my dad was never a dog
person
it was it was my mom sort of the kids
need it quan wants it i love doc so my
dad wasn't totally against dogs but to
your point it just was never part of
this history they didn't it just it's
just it's so recent that they were
hunting black people it was just it's
just recent i mean you know and like you
know and what's you know passed down
from the ancestral trauma or just from
you know and so i mean even in the 60s
like the police were training dogs to
attack black people so you look at those
those photos where they're like hosing
people down and the dogs are going after
them it's like you know and and it's an
awkward thing to bring up and it sounds
like a stereotype or whatever but you
know i just remember one time
you know i was dating uh this guy who
was black and he came into my house and
he played nfl football like he's a
very
dumb
could defend himself kind of person um
and i had my little like puppy was like
six months old and like ran up to him
and he like jumped on the table
and i was like how are you scared of
that
and he was like yeah my ancestors were
hunted by dogs like it's it's you know
it's just baked into the blood yeah it
was like so it might just be i'm not
saying it it's not just this person but
like it was something that i asked like
can i please hear more about this you
know so i can understand because the
psychological benefits of being able to
have a dog or a cat like are proven um
you know you sleep better you can have a
routine you have something that like to
be robbed of unconditional love today
because of that disgraceful past like
just it makes me nuts and i do not know
what to do about it i just keep bringing
it up and the other thing i was quickly
going to touch on is
going back to
to blacks in my profession it it doesn't
even register on the census there i mean
do you know of any can you think of any
black veterinarians i
knew one black veterinarian who was down
here uh at the uh closest vet to me and
he came out and uh
like when inside started talking about
the dogs i was like oh so where i've
like i've never
met you before like are you did you just
start working here and he goes yeah i
moved here because my uh wife had a job
here but we're gonna move back to new
jersey next month i was like oh no why
and he goes because la people are crazy
he's like i'm sick of like white women
yelling at me to like to clone their
dogs
he was just like so i do think if there
are more black vets they're not putting
up with la idiots
i mean they can go anywhere
but yes but the answer is no but if
there were more black veterinarians
maybe more people of color would
identify with the people giving their
pets care interesting yeah i was i was
running a track meet and i was sort of a
standout athlete um
and a
back in the day yeah yeah it was two
generations ago
but
a coach came up to me at the end of the
track me and said you have a lot of
talent like what what do you where do
you plan on taking that or what do you
want to do and i said i'm going to be a
veterinarian you know i'll start and i'm
probably six i'm gonna be a veterinarian
and he said to me
oh and he kind of chuckled i've never
i've never met a black vet before
that was his response to me
and i've never been a racist coach
before i'm a child and i said well i'm
going to be the first
what was interesting about this is
you're picturing a white coach the coach
was black whoa
so
maybe in some ways oh well then i that's
well he's been indoctrinated or his he
thought he could only take one path or
one lane that blacks were athletes and i
reflecting back on that moment
now i feel sorry for him like someone
probably told him the same thing like
you're you're just made to be a coach or
an athlete or this is what blacks in
america do it's
entertainment or sports or and so
you know in that moment it was almost
like he was just passing on what he knew
which is sad now i think back on that
moment i it's saddening to me yeah like
that was never on the table right
now
yeah you know yeah so i don't think he
was trying i've never seen a a white
gold medal sprinter
i should have yeah
i don't think that's on the table
[Music]
[Laughter]
just either of like self-limiting
beliefs but
oh wow that's fascinating uh i forgot my
train of thought because i was like you
probably shouldn't make that joke and i
shouldn't have well i think more i just
want to see more people of color in my
profession you know that'd be nice so
yes yes it is that's not going to happen
overnight but if if you if that's
something you want to do there should be
some sort of pathway
for you i love how we cover have we
covered every single topic or issue this
is wild i mean we're now we have to stop
because this is this is but now we're
just hanging out because i just miss you
and i love you and i'll i'll talk to you
forever um i love you and um
uh
the street vet instagram um follow we
will announce shortly when we're to be
doing like a 20 minute a week ig live so
you guys can ask questions you know save
them up be prepared we'll give you time
each week to you know not just hop on
and like you know say crazy shit and uh
don't ride elephants we love you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]